[Music]
hello everyone and good evening
this will be a wonderful wonderful
addition of viewers choice and I chose
four of these games out of many emails
and I have to say these people played
like 2800 s when they were 12 years old
so that's pretty good actually
and obviously I'm joking but these were
really good quality games and even
though there will be some mistakes here
and there they had some good thing going
on these games okay so let's start with
Elias to arts game this was a English
opening but it soon turns into a Slav
defense now this kind of surprised alia
that why didn't play d4 early and he was
saying in the email that he was
wondering how can he try to punish white
for this delay of d4 now I know a report
Richard very well and I saw him the
first time he made the GM norm and
instead of 97 what
Elia played the young Richard reports
played Bishop d6 with the idea of if
Bishop be to be five and there's a usual
trick in this position meaning if white
takes on d5 takes Knight b5 this is a
regular idea as white hits the b6 Bishop
and the e5 pawn simultaneously but now
comes reports idea he can play knight c6
and one go that he couldn't do if you
put your night on d7 and even though he
fought he
even though he parts with his bishop the
Queen and the pawn Center will
compensate for the lack of bishop pair
and he had a game I think again Pascal
and it was interesting game so you
played a 97 Queen c2 Bishop d6 we should
be to Castle Bishop b2 so while is
actually refusing to play d4 because
then black could eventually counter it
with E 5 not necessarily yet because
white can take on the five and Knight B
5
although black does have this Bishop b4
check and it all transposes into a long
line that Avon check Planes instead
black can play a six and after Bishop b2
play e5 and usually these positions are
quite pleasant for black as even though
he will have this isolated d5 pawn let's
save it C takes d5 C takes D 5 D takes
Knight takes e5 but after rook d1 and
Bishop e6 the d5 pawn will be very well
protected and the next move like will be
able to bring the rook and just spend
the night and black has very good
compensation and just if you're looking
for an approval from a great player I
just tell you that the black player was
none other than Gary Kasparov playing
this type of isolated pawn positions
with black so ok lie-detector whom we
don't know who who really is decided to
continue with his plan and only after if
I played d4
but actually he 5 is not a great idea
can somebody help me why he 5 was a
little bit too early for black
why was the e5 a little bit early
yeah takes takes night b5 and now this
would have been very good for the white
player because that's their Bishop be
eight rooks c1 and what really doesn't
have to fear efore because the knight
has a good spot on d4 also if black
plays something random let's say rook e8
then I can jump on c7 and this is very
advantageous it's not just that white
has a beautiful knight on d4 it's also
that he's getting the bishop there after
Bishop takes c7 Queen takes c7 this is a
very pleasant position for white so
Stewart should have played a6 first and
then II five the only other moment you
can play is if you're ready to just
sacrifice the bishop there and play
Bishop d6 early on and then e5 then C
tech C takes knight c6 other times you
must play a six to get ready with the e5
break but anyways why decided to play d4
even though we should have taken on d5 I
think d4 and Stewart said in the email
that he was thinking how he can punish
wide for this delay of d4 and I think he
found a way he for is in fact the
correct way to play these positions 92
and now the correct move was a six
stopping all of these ideas of C take C
takes Knight B fives and these are big
threats
so if black will play rook e8 takes
takes Knight b5 this can turn into very
annoying position because if you think
about it this position is basically a
reversed French and in fact it's an ID
to French as the night on d7 is similar
to the knight on D 2 so black played a6
which is a very good move stabilizing
the Queen side
and what really needs to play precisely
here because otherwise he will lose
because of the lack of space and if we
remember the idea of French positions we
might find a typical break in this
position can anyone help me what is the
typical break in this position if we
imagine that we're actually playing a
French with black colours that's
basically why this playing a reversed
French how can we try to undermine the
d5 pawn f3 is a usual way but that would
be a bit too aggressive at the moment
because it would make this e3 pawn
business felt
it is
what's defending that d5 pawn yeah the
c6 phone and the knight on f6 now we're
already putting pressure on the c6 pawn
kind of holding its ground for the
moment so we can't really do anything
with the c6 bomb right now but can we do
something with that about that night on
f6 g4 exactly
now this g4 idea was played by many good
players among them is a von Schuch
and they von Schuch is a great player we
all know that so g4 is an interesting
idea trying to undermine black center
and it's a playable position with mutual
chances because even though sometimes
white wins the d5 pawn but then this
Jeep on can also get weak but why play
castles which is very normal and now
black pit played a very good plan rook
e8 b5 could be a potential idea but it's
kind of risky as it would weaken the
queenside structure rook e8 is very good
and solid the idea of bringing the
knight to f/8 and I think Stuart's plan
of bringing the Knight to g6 is very
good because that's how you should play
and it's very normal the rook defends
the e4 pawn while the knight on d7 is
rushing to reach the h4 square through
g6 and night h4 so not a fate h3 96
rook e1 Bishop e6 and actually white is
slowly running out of time so he might
need to look for a break what kind of
breaks might can look in this position
I mean g4 is obviously out of question
because we just castled there so no no
that you shouldn't do that
yeah f3 and for better or worse the only
way to just try to survive is to
undermine the c4 pawn and after it takes
either Knight takes f3 I think it works
or Bishop takes f3 and I think because
of this annoying Knight age 4 that would
attack the g2 and the f3 Bishop black is
slightly better or even much better but
this is still the only chance for white
to go for a game otherwise he'll just be
overrun by an attack which will happen
not in the fashion that it should happen
but it will happen
so why plays c5 and now black commits a
mistake
where should we bring our Bishop like
didn't move his bishop but he should
have where would you in the audience who
and where where would we bring the
bishop from d6 bishop where we should be
8 or where else
mm-hmm so Bishop b8 is an idea as you
correctly mentioned let's say if why
this oblivious and place B for Queen c7
could be a nice little battery yes but
this bishop on B it can get awfully
passive and it also disconnects the
rooks you don't want that bishop f8
would be a bit tad bit too passive and
wouldn't do much there so I know chess
chess is terrible because there's so
many options and none of them is perfect
so I still go with Bishop c7 because the
bishop will be useful on this diagonal
and will help us attack the White King
but doesn't disrupt our coordination
like Bishop b8 would and the problem
with Bishop b8 and even though this
battery can be set up but then white can
play bent Larson's favorite move which
will which would stop everything
not f1 Beth Larson's favorite move is
good to remember because this move
anytime you can make it and it doesn't
lose a piece it defends your King side
forever bent Larsen used to say if you
manage to bring your knight to f1 or f8
that means you're never gonna get
checkmated ever again I mean in that
game so he played a 97 not a great move
and white said thank you
but Elia wasn't perturbed and felt that
okay at least I have an attack and he
went for it
and that's a good thing to do even if
you make mistakes at least try to throw
your opponent off and try to made them
somehow and it works in this game now
white plays Queen d1 but there's a
better defending move for white what
would that be
yeah night f1 again not f1 is a winner
because if Queen g5 there's this very
nice covering move Nigeria and basically
there's no more attack because the night
covers everything and the pawn I do oh
just defends the White King forever the
other way to defend is this usual way of
bringing the bishop to f1 covering the
g2 square and F Queen g5 we can do it
old man style and just move our king
away to h1 so there's no Bishop H h3
trickery because we just take and if you
would claim that there's a pen there is
an open there and if everything is
falling why can still play g3 and
because of this great defender on f1
white is not gonna have any troubles
also not after he doesn't work which
would be annoying in general the knight
can just take and we're a piece up but
okay white played Queen d1 Queen g5
Bishop g4 but this age 5 move was very
good just chasing away this defender g3
h6 g4g takes Queen takes h4 so actually
black has real compensation I'm not sure
if it's winning but this Bishop is just
too powerful so it does compensate for
the lack of a piece so H takes g4 Bishop
g4 and now white decides to play f3 a
lots wrong with Queen c2 though
I can wipe on it what how can I get
punished that's the Queen City
yeah Bishop f3y needs to take e.t xf3
the King can't run anymore which is
annoying because that would be just
Queen age one mate and end of the game
the only way to defend in these
positions is to bring the Queen closer
you should this stops everything
suddenly so luck is still lost in this
position or some reason because if rook
e6
maid would be close but there's queen
takes f3 and white survives at least for
the moment
so f3 was played
but then Queen jeez g3 check King gauge
1 and rookie 6 just finishes it off
because not Brooke age 6 comes there's
no way to stop that mate even if white
would try to bring bring a plea bring a
piece to e2 then root age 6 check comes
and rook takes h2 mates so this was a
very good game in general like Elias
turd you had the idea right but you have
to defend your Bishop on d6
everything else you did correctly apart
from this early e5 move which you should
support first with a 6 so remember to
play a 6 first and then e5 and also save
your bishops
so the second game was a correspondence
game between ackerman Andrew and through
hello Julian
which is going to be a Dutch defense the
for f5 to g3 not a3 Bishop g7 and as
Eckerman points it out d5 is not the
best move here
d6 is much better in general in these
positions when you play f5 in any
scenario be prepared to be worse because
your king is kind of weakened after the
pawn push and any other pawn moves just
make your position much worse so this
little pawn move on d6 would have been
much better than d5 because now honestly
this position just looks like a Swiss
cheese which is tasty but not good in
chess
so d5 it's not good I would prefer d6
with the idea of at least bringing
another pawn to the center so d5 and
Ackerman correctly takes it Knight takes
Knight c3 c6 Bishop g5 Queen e8 now
Queen e8 is not a great move Queen d6
swords would be much better kind of
trying to hold the position together and
because of all these weaknesses on e5
and c5 and c4 and everywhere
White is just much much better but it's
still not hopeless that you can play
these positions and hope for the best
but why this is clearly better Queen e8
Queen b3 Queen d7 and my favorite moves
from Black Knight takes d5 I'm not a big
fan of exchanging already on d5 maybe
rook d1 would be a nice move I know you
mentioned Knight e5 which is obviously a
computer move
the computers are great at checkers and
go and whatever but not in chess
so Bishop takes D takes c6 and it's
still gonna get a close up position it's
not obviously white it's clearly better
but it's not winning yet I like rook FD
one better it's more thematic and you'll
play Knight e5 when it's really calm
when it really counts so Knight d5 C
takes Knight e5 and Bishop takes e5 is a
good move by your opponent because this
vision is terrible and exchanging in a
bad position is always a good idea
and obviously the King side is a little
bit weakened now but at least the closet
position closed up a bit route c1 knight
c6 Bishop f6 h5 I'm not thrilled with
this move h5 black should somehow pull
his pieces together play something like
rook b8 with the idea of let's say a 3 B
6 and after rook c2 Bishop e7 and now
this the position looks bearable like is
obviously worse but there are still
fighting chances in these positions h5
was too much h5 is not doing anything at
the moment look at d1 the normal move
and I like it because you're kind of
preparing the e4 break which actually
works much better because of this h5
bush because the bishop on e4 will hit
on g6 so that'll be great
a5 a3 slow maneuvering game but it's
fine Queen c7 not a great move I still
like the idea of rook b8 better but then
what would have an extra move that would
just stop all black ideas what would
that be
how can might stop black from playing b6
Bishop b7 yeah
Queen b6 yeah of course just stopping it
and she's just dominating the position
and like it's basically in suits wrong
there's no way out of this position
Queen c7 rug d2 Queen b8 not the best
well in general black moves around with
the Queen too much you need to develop
those beautiful pieces on the Queen side
you need them otherwise you'll lose and
that's why black lost so 95 takes h5 a3
Queen c7
yeah please play rugby 8 next time and
b6 not bouquet 7 that wouldn't make your
life easier
Queen c7 rugby - Queen Bee 8 and to be
frank unsurprisingly
White has a sacrifice in this position
which is rook takes d5 how does rook
takes d5 win
the reason the sacrifice is not so
surprising it's because the rook on
eight is not playing and the bishop on
seed is not playing either so basically
why it was a rook and Bishop up the
whole game so obviously this rook
sacrifice should work on principle
so obviously black takes bishop takes
King gage seven and this Bishop g8 is a
very nice move I have to admit that
because if the King moves to h6 check
goodbye and so nice mate just bishops
and Queens but obviously black took
check can get six takes Bishop e6 mate
but this was a good game for white not
as much for black but in principle if
you have big development try to open up
the position as quickly as possible
so I could have tried to open up with E
for a little bit quicker maybe III was a
nice move so you gave a space on a two
but e e4 would be a little bit more
brutal and I would have preferred that
one because you would win like five
moves earlier also black needs to keep
it closed otherwise you get the same
position and this Dutch so in Dutch
positions try to keep the position
closed and you can hope for your life
and if you open it up well start hoping
otherwise you'll just lose most likely
you lose so keep it closed if you play
the Dutch and if your whites just open
up the position and win easily all right
that was a promo for the Dutch defence
and this game was sent by Nicolas lor
again someone I don't know
so I named him anonymous was also played
on an online server I think Jess calm
and my play d4 b 6d for Bishop b7 now b6
is a good move if you're Magnus Carlsen
and it it's not bad if you're Richard
report otherwise it's not the best move
on the planet
I've seen better moves like c5 is pretty
good Fischer likes this move Fischer is
also a good player II five is not a bad
move that bit boring but it's good si
six is exciting don't play that you'll
have a fun game d5 is a bad move but fun
move c6 this is a good move but it's
solid and you'll have you'll have a bit
more excitement than an e5 d6 is a fun
move but not a great one all right we've
looked at plenty of moves you can choose
to your liking there like five other
moves that you can choose b6 is not my
favorite okay d4 this should be seven
Bishop d3 well 92 would be a nice move
because as you'll see later on e6 Bishop
d3 the idea of Bishop b4 is not as great
as if the knight would be on c3 because
y can just play C 3 immediately chasing
away the bishop and you will be a happy
camper
so Bishop d3 e6 you can just develop
your knight
there's no rush you don't need to play
c4 because now you transpose back to
variation from d4 variations like d 4e 6
c4 b6 now I'm more thrilled with this
v6y because this is cold I think the
English variation played by Tony miles
and Nigel short so this is this is much
better than e4b six actually to be
honest cousin played neither 3 v6 here
so after this Bishop d7 the situation
improved a bit I still think you should
play c5 instead unless you're Magnus
cousin and you're watching this play b6
it doesn't matter
so b6 d4 so yeah coming back to this one
b6 this is a more respectable version of
doing ecigs b6 in this case cuz II for
Bishop b7 and after Knight c3 you can
attack the knight and pin the knight on
c3 so this is fun thingy for B 6 is less
fun because you usually don't get the
chance to pin the Knight Bishop d3 y 6c
4 and age six was played but you can
just play Bishop b4 check and if white
plays the passive Knight d2 you just
laugh and have a good game if he plays
Bishop d2 then it'll be challenging if
he plays Knight c3 you actually achieved
your goal it shouldn't really happen
because Bishop d2 is the better move
here and you exchange Queen d2 and white
is better but black didn't know that so
you waited one move I'm not thrilled
with this h6 moves though if you want to
wait around follow a grandmaster called
Spassky who played g6 wait Knight c3
Bishop g7 and this is McShane's favorite
can anyone tell me what opening is this
for block
yeah the hippo which is everyone's
favorite I mean spassky's and Maxine's
favorite nobody plays it because it's
not good but Bishop b4 check you should
play if you want to try to play this
position so h6 Knight c3 Bishop b4 a3
not the best move because in general
black wants to [ __ ] your structure
and you'll get this NIM so type
structures and usually black will have a
fun time so you should have played
something like what what should white
play in this position you see - Bishop
d2 Bishop d2 is amazing here just
notifying this idea black takes white
takes you get the bishop there for free
and you'll be better if you play Queen
c2 it kind of feels funny a little bit
here usually in Queens seen two names
are Indians they do it because Bishop d2
and those early stages is not a good
move Bishop d2 here is more normal
because you already own the center you
already own the e4 square so Bishop e7
Knight f3 d6 Castle Knight f6 v 5 9 8 7
not the best what should white I mean
black tried to do here
for a good reason black played d6 you
should follow up with a plan with the
plan he had in mind so D takes e5 would
be the right move
and if D takes e5 I'd rather prefer the
knight to move it to the 7 and these
positions are actually tricky because
even though the black pieces are a bit
passive this a 5 pawn can become weak in
the long run you can see this position
positions in a lack of a kind defenses
let's say we'll move back and back a
little bit Knight f6 b5
come on d5 95 d4 t69 f3 c6 Bishop e2
Bishop g4 let's say castles Bishop takes
after it takes takes takes c6 and this
is a typical position you can find
plenty of car yakin short rapid games on
this one where Kuryakin 1y can play C
497 and in the long run short than
anyone who plays this type of positions
they're trying to play against this ePHI
pawn but White has a slight advantage
because of the space advantage but Black
has its own Black has his own play of
going ninety seven ninety sixth ranked
on their mind on e5 all right coming
back to the game page six Bishop d3 a3
it should be seven Knights 386 so you
should have definitely I mean black
should have definitely taken on e5 and
play Knight at thee 797 Bishop c4 is a
good move why is this should be for such
a fantastic move here
what do you think
yeah he's trying to weaken the white
squares and also the only good piece
that black has is this Bishop on b7 so
after c6 job is well done for white
because there's no more good pieces for
black between c2 just asking where this
Knight is headed Knight g5 Knight takes
Bishop e3 Bishop e3 is a solid move but
I think there's one slightly better move
here and that is f4 just trying to
attack black while he's still on Castle
why does itah move later but I mean if
you can do it immediately do it
immediately Queen c7 F 4 there should be
seven f5 takes g6 and I can see that
everyone loves sacrifices these days so
rook takes takes f7 doesn't really
surprise me now King takes f7 Bishop
takes g6 and like the same theme from
the other game we can see that rook on
a8 is not quite developed yet so
sacrifice is more than likely to be good
King g7 broke f1 hope I jumped a little
bit okay faith Bishop takes h6 takes
Bishop 8 7 and
there's nowhere to hide how can we
finish off black in this position black
has basically won pretty okay move here
yeah King g5 running to the hills but no
Hills there
in g6
Queen f5 mates so in general it's a
check oh it's just a check ah
such a shame okay so Queen e4 and let's
just slide down yeah here 94 is fine but
Queen g6 just sliding down and mating on
c2 ISM slightly nicer so it's a nice
mate but black really needs to develop
those pieces on the Queen side that's
the moral of the story white needs to
avoid these bad pawn structures unless
he really wants to mate then it doesn't
matter you can ruin your structure but
then meet your opponent okay so the last
game it's coming up and that's pretty
good game by the Slovenian player next
Urgell in the SS he told me in the email
he said I was looking to play a position
similar to the Argentinian tragedy well
let's see how it goes before c5 Bishop
yeah that was like three games but who
was the innovator of that game
yeah so Sergio plays Knight d7 which I
think unbeknownst to him is a deviation
from the urgent in Ian's tragedy because
aged six is the move Bishop h4 g5 takes
and Knight f d7 as the move takes F
takes Queen age five King f8 there
should be five and as he points it out
after week eight sevens a long long line
and who knows what goes on there
actually the innovator who played this
Bishop b5 move was none other than the
person who always went second and never
first who is he not Geller Paul Karras
so poor Karras who was forced to play
for the Soviet Union even though he's he
was Estonian and he had to switch
Federation's because the country was
annexed at the time played this amazing
bombshell against the Argentinians and
their team won 3-0 all the board's they
played this Bishop b5 idea they won the
game so remember Paul Karras he was an
amazing player so 97 castles Bishop h4
g5 F takes G 595 and I have to applaud
the black player for being so creative
even though he missed a very nice idea
of by white here what can white play
here
well yes bond takes f6 Knight takes f3
and pawn takes a seven in c 7g - exactly
and this kind of reminds me of Fischer
games where he had three pieces against
the Queen and in general that's a good
trade for the one who has the pieces so
even after b5 we have like tactics
galore here for white y can sacrifice
like anything can go Knight f5 because
it takes the knight d5 and every kind of
tactics work or just the more lacks
Bishop digs b5 and winning because if a
takes Knight takes b5 the Queen moves
Knight takes c6 check and Knight takes
f7 and we are on the roll and we're
gonna win everything including this game
so you play the Queen e2 and after that
night f d7 there is no Knight takes c6
anymore because these Knights are much
better place now so for good reason your
opponent played King B you want H takes
g5 Bishop takes f2 I mean Bishop f2 in
this game black will play amazingly b5
a3 which should be 7 does this position
look similar to you can anyone remember
someone who just came out of retirement
playing a similar position it could
because Faro of I'm most likely he is
the one
yeah this this reminded me of his game
against Dominguez and this game will be
no less amazing black is playing pretty
good here so G for black plays rook c8
Bishop g2 and pal rook takes c3 and this
is a well found that sacrifice and
usually works in the Sicilian because
white will get a structural weakness and
as I learned recently doubled pawns
actually are worth one pawn so basically
the pawn structure and the doubled pawns
compensate for the material deficit for
black so Queen a5 hitting all those
pawns Knight be three twin takes c3
Bishop d4 Queen c7 and after the job
well done
the black queen drops back to c7 so can
someone help me evaluate this position
who's better who's worse what are the
odds someone's gonna win this game
yeah black like it's clearly better why
is black really better
yeah the king is very well protected in
the center White's King gets terrible
yeah also White's pawn structures are
horrible as well so yeah so even though
black is down material he is better I'd
even venture as far as black in the long
run must win this game because White's
position is prospectus there's nothing
you can do
you're basically just waiting for black
to execute his plan and you'll just be
waiting
so King gate h4 takes Bishop b2 route g8
push your page 3 that's c4 bishops
Yvonne Knight de5 non-id e5 is a fine
move but is there any other plans why I
mean black could do in this position
yennai db6 the plan of night a for and
this won't be fun after night a for
route d3
you might even risk Bishop f6 making a
dragon bishop out of this neither of
bishop and the end is near for white so
I think that b6 would have been slightly
better tonight the five boom g1 Bishop
g5 takes takes King gate to Bishop g5
was a good move though because black is
getting rid of the only good defender of
White's position six King gate to a 594
green c5 in that III pawn is kind of
weak can I defend that pawn without
losing any material
yeah it's difficult
so rook d3 would be the only idea but
that will lose material and I didn't
want that in general though it should
have been played though because if black
takes at least we've got rid of that
nasty knight on e5 and white is not that
much down in material here Knight takes
v5 just loses a piece Dix rugby one
queen c5 black loves putting his queen
on c5 I can see rook takes b7 queen g1
rugby 3 and guess what the villain of
this game returns to c5 yet again
causing havoc and devastation in f1 a 4
and now out of desperation my played
rugby for takes c3 Queen takes c3 Ruby 8
king e7 green f2 and Queen c2 check is a
bit
- solid for my taste maybe I don't know
night see -
and just having a made threat here there
everywhere would be slightly better
Queen c2 is also winning them and after
Queen c2 not exceed two but resigned for
a good reason he's down too many
material so apart from an early hiccup
from the Slovenian player meaning night
if I wasn't the best cos GTX f6 could
have been played and what would have
been much better in general and should
be winning black played a model game and
this is how you should play this
position when you own the center and you
have a stable knight on e5 and this was
actually very similar to the game played
between Kasparov and Dominguez where
Kasparov was black and I advise you to
check that out it was played recently at
the simplest blitz and rapid so this was
viewers choice and see you next time on
viewers Choice
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]